a dancing killer robot doll a spy
Thriller inspired by an iconic video
game Air Jordans even JLo 2023 has it
all and these are the year's best films
so far 2023 kicked off with Megan an
instant horror icon Megan took the
Internet by storm before her film even
hit theaters thanks to a meme heavy
marketing campaign her movie is even
better a highly Advanced Android with a
charming smile Megan is paired with
Katie a young girl a reeling from the
loss of her parents at first Megan
provides her with comfort and care but
things get ugly when Megan gets
possessive thrilling clever and wickedly
funny Megan is one of the best new
horror comedies in years it sounds like
you're fighting we're not fighting and
avant-garde horror film made for only
fifteen thousand dollars skinny marink
Chronicles the experience of two
children who encounter a malevolent
spirit in their home the film is also
shot in a grainy black and white so your
eyes are constantly tricked into looking
for faces in the shadows moreover apart
from barely audible Whispers And the
occasional shockingly loud noise the
movie is basically silent although not
entirely plotless skinny marink is an
eerie nightmarish mood piece that will
make you afraid of the shadowy corners
of your own home so when you do go to
sleep after watching it you can count on
having some very weird dreams true to
form writer director M Night shyamalan's
latest movie has divided critics and
audiences like most of his films
knockout the cabin has a sinisterly
simple premise a family's rural getaway
is interrupted by four strangers who
claim that the world will end unless a
family sacrifices one of their own after
you make what I know is an impossible
decision
you must then kill the one you choose
shot mostly in a single location with a
cast of seven characters knock at the
cabin is another reliable example of
shyamalan's prowess as a director so
fans of his old work will be satisfied
but if you couldn't get into the
melodrama and moralizing of 2021's old
and then knock at the cabin probably
isn't for you elevated horror is all
well and good but sometimes all you need
is an hour and a half of young people
making questionable choices in the face
of Doom set during the height of the
covid-19 pandemic sick finds a small
click of college students quarantined in
a lake house it's there that they become
targeted by a faceless killer Kevin
Williamson co-wrote the screenplay so
the film is armed with a cutting witch
you'd expect from the writer of scream
sick also digs into the Cavalier
attitudes towards the pandemic and the
search to place blame for the suffering
it caused occasionally critics will
confuse a silly movie as being a stupid
movie shotgun wedding is a deeply and
wonderfully silly movie Tom and Darcy
are a couple whose destination wedding
is raided by pirates from there noise
see bloody violence ensues as far as
action rom-coms go shotgun wedding is on
power the lost city a similarly goofy
Date Movie from 2022 that received much
more favorable reviews neither film is
hayat but both are Lively popcorn
Adventures for grown-ups was a kid's
sense of humor
from 10. what is this a rocket launch
shotgun wedding treats his storyline
with delightful absurdity while all the
actors are having the time of their
lives since the foot is so contagious
shotgun wedding is an enjoyable watch
2015's Creed Remains the finest example
of Hollywood's current recall Trend that
film continued the legacy of boxer Rocky
Balboa with the new protagonist who is
essentially his opposite the latest
chapter in The Saga of Adonis Creed is
the first to exclude Rocky completely it
also proves that the new champ is
totally capable of standing on his own
don't let him destroy everything you've
built following in the tradition of his
predecessor leading man Michael B Jordan
has taken the directing Reigns he's also
put his own visual stump on the film by
incorporating anime influences from
Dragon Ball Z whether you're a hardcore
fan of the Rocky movies or simply a
casual viewer Creed 3 is an exciting and
emotional Blockbuster that holds up
alongside the best installments of the
franchise Keanu Reeves and his former
stunt double Chad tehelski have done it
again with John Wick chapter 4. the
spectacular new entry in their epic this
time the Unstoppable assassin is
surrounded by an exciting Ensemble of
global action stars like hiroyuki Sanada
Scott Adkins and Donnie Yen as a results
the martial arts Mayhem is brought up to
a newer more exciting level more than
ever John Wick's fight sequences
demonstrate the degree of craft and
Imagination that has no equal at least
in the Western Hemisphere though it's
the longest entry in the series at a
whopping 169 minutes John Wick chapter 4
dispensers with most of its law and
World building at the very top so the
rest of the runtime is an almost
continuous marathon of Gunplay sword
fights and vehicular Warfare
simultaneously gorgeous revolting and
hilarious John Wick remains an absolute
Gem of modern action Cinema after
successfully rebooting hora's most
reliable franchise in 2022 the directing
Duo of Mata Betten eliopin and Tyler
Gillette have followed up quickly with
Scream 6. the sequel brings a surviving
Woodsboro gang to the Big Apple where
they face yet another stab-happy killer
in a ghost face mask while Legion
installment internal scream series
usually Rifts on his place in the horror
franchise Scream 6 takes a different
route don't you know the Legacy
characters are disposable now nobody
cares about last centuries Heroes as a
relatively unprecedented sequel to a
recall the film establishes that there's
no clear road map to follow Anything Can
Happen anyone can die and no one can be
trusted while this lack of a clear
Mission makes it one of the least
focused chapters in the ongoing saga
Scream 6 still offers terrific tension
and gnarly kills we also got to spend
more time with the lovable Ensemble
introduced in 2022's Scream who proved
to be more than capable of carrying the
franchise for years to come over 20
years after the disastrous first attempt
at Dungeons and Dragons film franchise
whiter directors Jonathan M Goldstein
and John Francis Daly have struggled
with an uproarious fantasy Adventure
honor among Thieves centers around a
Charming group of characters who are
brought to life by stars that are
clearly having a blast their Quest
captures a feeling of a great DND
campaign with your friends characters
with tragic backstories band together
and heal each other's emotional wounds
complex challenges are also solved by
bizarre imaginative or downright
unpredictable means plans go awry
monsters are Unleashed and the grand
time is had by all whether you're
immersed in the mythology of the
decades-old game or just coming along
for the ride honor among Thieves won't
disappoint in a landscape dominated by
huge effects-driven franchises the once
Mighty romantic comedy has become a
niche genre in order to catch the
Public's attention modern rom-coms
typically need to be mashups with
flashier genres as in Palm Springs or
shotgun wedding not to knock those
efforts but sometimes a simple story
about two Charming characters falling in
love works best that's exactly what
makes rylane so refreshing it's
essentially an entire movie built around
the concept of meet cute so in the film
audiences get to see a likable would be
couple getting to know each other over
the course of a single day in South
London clever colorful and shamelessly
and complicated Ry Lane is the perfect
date movie 2023's weirdest Hollywood
trend is a business biopic these types
of films tell the stories behind famous
products or brands from Air Jordans to
Flamin Hot Cheetos alongside the growth
of this new sub-genre has been the
meteoric rise of the video game
adaptation director Jonas Baird's Tetris
is riding both of these ways presenting
a dramatized version of the Intrigue
surrounding the popular game it stars
Taryn Edgerton as Hank Rogers a
struggling video game executive who
travels to the Soviet Union to bring
Tetris to the West Tetris is a comedy
that fits neatly into the shape of a spy
thriller so it's certainly the year's
most unexpected video game movie in 2022
longtime creative collaborators Ben
Affleck and Matt Damon launched their
new production company art says Equity
the company aims to give filmmakers a
piece of the profits of the films they
make so it's appropriate that the first
release from artists Equity should be
about the intersection between business
arts and celebrity hairstyles Damon is
sunny Vaquero head of the struggling
basketball Division at Nike in 1984. in
the film
rookie he believes will change the game
I need the greatest basketball shoe
that's ever been made who's the player
Michael Jordan the mostly true story of
the betting War over Jordan's
endorsement makes for a surprisingly fun
light drama but it also speaks to the
Studio's mission of reconsidering the
relationship between talented people and
those who invest in them that may sound
like dry stuff but air never becomes
more about business than it is about
people and that's how it should always
be do you ever lie awake at night
thinking about the future climate
apocalypse and the powerful institutions
that would likely profit from it then
you'll probably enjoy how to blow up a
pipeline one of the year's best films
how to blow up a pipeline is a tight
Thriller that explores the many ways
today's terrifying environmental
realities radicalizing young people to
save the world the film makes such a
compelling argument that even the FBI
has issued several warnings about it
according to a rolling stone report